欢迎收听赵华与股获在第1127集
今天是2026年的6月26号星期五了
这个礼拜三个字做白宫
做白宫
今天指数是大跌
盘中有跌到大概1800多点
中场下跌了1680几点
是史上的第三大跌点
怎么讲做白宫呢
这礼拜一我们是看到史上的高点
以现货市场来说是48000多点
以期货市场来说是49000多点
等于在礼拜一的时候
你会觉得5万根本不是什么了不起的
好的
今天的收盘
以现货市场来说
已经跌到了44571点了
5万跟44000
这个感受就差很多
那真正的跌点
以现货来说大概3800多点
期货有将近5000点
因为我们有讲旗子之前是一个正价差
今天把这个正价差也通通吐回去了
也就是今天期货的收盘比现货还要低
好 听到声音了
我们今天有影片版
好 我们今天是有影片版
我先来欢迎星期五
我们的固定星期五男孩
我们的国家级基金操盘手黄丰凯凯哥
早好 各位观众听众大家好
我记得你上个礼拜是礼拜四来
不是星期五男孩
但我们也有露营
结果今天的指数已经跌回到上个礼拜一的开盘了
没错
对
政大很大
一个A型
白做工
真的叫白做工
白做工的情况下
我想最近的环境
昨天也有比较详细跟大家分享
就是升息和收缩资金的这个问题
从美元的走势就知道
美国真的开始有点担心
是不是9月要升所谓的第一吗
那韩国又有所谓的去杠杆的一些想法
台湾呢
不晓得大家没有收到通知
就是您的券商有没有让你融资买台积电
已经有非常多包括像元大吧
已经告诉大家台积电不能用融资
那我今天也有说到像期货商
也有告诉大家
你不能再去申请调高你流畅的部位了
这些就是在收缩资金上面
已经也有一些政策和对策出来了
所以美国 韩国 台湾现在都有收缩资金
我觉得这是这一波后来变成一个
有点像是A型反转的一个原因
当然就是说
其实全球都看到
就是全球的资本市场都很热
那台湾不用讲
我们现在上次有讲过
就是说这次跟之前网络泡沫不太一样
这次网络泡沫是全世界都在涨
然后整个下去
可是这次的这个AI泡沫
应该讲还没有泡沫
就只有强几个国家
就是美国 日本 台湾 韩国
三个国家特别的强
那今天早上其实一开盘的时候
其实大家有点摸不着头绪
就是说怎么好像跌的蛮重的
但其实昨天晚上美国的PPI
就开了这一枪
就告诉你说
看起来景气有点过热的现象
当然因为还有一个油价助长的原因
所以其实现在一个两难的局面
就是说到底他9月份
会不会真的去做预防性升息的动作
现在变成大家有点磨泥两可
因为之前很多人都讲铁定不会
可是现在大家看起来都说好像会
所以这个地方基本上
我觉得不管是WASH
基本上他们都很难
其实川普更难
因为他还想要做多其中选举
那所以这就造成今天
整个亚洲股市一开盘就笼罩了气氛
因为今天台股还没开盘
日经跟韩国一开盘
基本上就是大跌的现象
所以那时候我就说
今天台股大概不太好
可是今天台股其实是
确实是比较弱的
你仔细看今天日本跟韩国
其实都有收一个小V
他有收一个小角上来
可是台湾是扎扎实实的收最低
收最低
几乎最低
对
那这有个原因就是因为
台湾的散温因为前一天都没在怕
今天突然有点害怕
今天感觉寒风起来
感觉昨天这个台风没有走
还在台湾的上空笼罩
今天就感觉特别的冷
尤其是中小谷
那我刚刚在跟赵达讲说
仔细看贵买的月线已经下弯了
那通常贵买月线下弯就不是一件好事情
就告诉你说
短线那个强势的多头
暂时高一个段落
那接下来可能就进入个修正的行情
那所幸的是
不管是日本 韩国或台湾的大盘指数
目前月薪都还在往上走
所以我们基本上还是认为
它是一个修正
所以我们刚才讲说
就是白做工了
就是上礼拜做多的这一段
又要休息了
可能要等再找下一个机会
再重新回来做多
那今天盘中其实
有一些比较遗憾的
就是我们上礼拜推荐的
我们讲的族群
像矽晶圆 像废斯圆圆圆
其实在这个礼拜上班
其实都还算蛮强的
一直到这两天
就开始陆续吐回来了
但是其实我觉得
他们还是趋势还在这里
所以不用太担心
因为政府摆明了告诉你说
你们不要一直往AI去
就是说他觉得AI已经涨过头了
已经涨多了
就是你让他稍微休息一下
其实他鼓励大家把资金往非AI的地方去
只是市场在那边读懂
不管是资本市场的表态的意思
或者是政府意图的作为
因为你看我们刚才讲说
连台铁的融资都被限缩了
被限缩
那大家讲说
为什么投信就可以买到25%台积电
政府为什么不帮散户把融资比例再开高一点
那但是因为他也会害怕
因为现在大家都在讲说
什么六代同堂
五代同堂
已经变六代对不对
然后很多企业组都一直在高喊说
各位员工们你们不要一直在做股票
你们要认真上班
包括四个人就一个人
这个上班的时候是开着手机在看股票
这怎么统计的我很怀疑
我是不知道有没有这么明显
但是确实我在某一家电台的时候
就看到很多同仁都在看股票
我们也是啦
很多同仁
不太一样啊
因为我们是财经台嘛
没错
看股票是正常的
我们是工作
可是他们不是财经台啊
怎么很多同仁都在看股票
这根本确实股票已经
再再的影响到市场的一些状况
我正在想说
只要你有赚到月薪
就可能考虑要地磁层
哇塞不得了耶
你才赚一个月薪就要地磁层
那像这几天这样
一下兔你不是
兔掉不是一个月薪
可能是半年薪都没有了
所以我觉得接下来指数
我觉得还是可以观察一下
观察什么
观察今天相对抗跌的族群
抗跌的族群
那今天相对比较弱的
你可能要先避开来了
我们待会再跟赵华座进一步的聊
那基本上目前看起来
大盘的一个
站稳的一个位置大概43,800
现在离不远了
所以它接下来可能还会下去
可能会破
但它开始站稳43,800
大概这行情就进入一个
重新要重新启动的一个格局
那期货其实大概在43,600
所以大家也可以稍微观察一下
这些位置什么时候可以直稳
那今天我刚刚讲
今天盘中里面其实载板算很强
为什么载板很强
因为载板其实在这一两周
都在密集的跟客户讲说
要涨报价
涨报价
包括像南电 景硕
其他客户讲说要调整报价
那涨幅分别从5%到15%都有
所以就看会怎么最近特别的强
其实因为还是那个概念
就是涨价题材
我如果没记得到
昨天吕电龙也是大涨的
昨天吕电龙说他要涨价
所以昨天吕电龙充涨停
但今天就
这个涨价题材就一下子而已
就没有办法刺激很久
因为他们已经涨很多了
所以股价涨很多的时候
你在讲说要涨价
基本上他可能就变成是
利用利多在出货
利多在出货
那回过来看
就是说我们除了刚刚讲的那些以外
其实今天还有一个很特殊的族群
就是食音元件
食音元件今天特别强
没错
因为我前天还在跟赵凰讲说要注意
因为市场上有大户已经开始在撤退了
是
那大户在撤退什么
他在撤退记忆体
他在撤退这些相关涨比较多的
那我觉得他们一定也感觉到说
盘氏可能相对来讲也涨的比较多了
所以他们做部分的撤退
但是基本上因为主力不是涵盖所有的股票
你要知道主力一定是他特别遇到哪些族群
他可能对哪些族群比较深入的研究
所以他可能有些族群是没有走或者是有些族群他们可能没有涉掠例如说像细光子这一块基本上离开了这批人基本上他们就比较没有涉掠
所以你看今天像
这个讯星KY
盘充一度从跌停拉到平盘
就告诉你说
其实他们是没有退场的
所以接下来这个还是可以看一下
那他有退场的
包括记忆体跟被动元件
使用元件
基本上你也发觉到说
好像也没有这么的弱
今天裡面其實最弱其實是被動元件
其實記憶體隨著美光牆
還跟著牆上來了
但是這個地方基本上
記憶體反而是要特別注意
因為確實韓國如果
這個新聞如果是屬實
就是Hanis要回來做DDR
覺得台灣廠商就是很不利
是很不利
而且基本上我們基本上是挨著打的
因為他們的技術本來就毫不疑慮
只是他不要把產能掉播過來而已
所以這就實時的衝擊
但是背後我覺得他是長多
但是你看我說
它在调整呢
基本上
备用键水还是有拉涨停的
所以我觉得
也没有完全的
就是壁空
就实质的反应出来
没有
那实际元件更不用讲
今天还有能量在涨停
投机档哦
对
那能量在涨停
主要是因为
在这个西华的股东会上
他们有讲说
目前看起来
实际元件很缺货
而且国际大厂的交期
拉很长了
所以他们感觉上
他们有机会可以补
感觉好像都是补
就是我们机械也是补
我们实际元件也是补
我们备用键也是补
就是补大厂的不足
大涨的缺短缺的部分
所以看起來還是有一些族群在醞釀
沒有完全的熄火
所以我認為這個大盤
看起來還是比較偏於修正
好 要先把大前提跟大家聊對不對
剛剛我們有提到收縮資金的事情
這個已經有點蔓延開來了
而且也不是講一天兩天
其實政府從講四代同堂變成六代同堂
就是已經覺得符合過多
還有要看一個事情
我們在五月底的時候也歷經過一次修正
那一次现货市场达到4万2
可是融资超级无敌勇敢
我们当然也有讲这一波融资
涨得跟以前不一样
也有很多所谓的热钱聪明融资
大户融资在里面
但是你也可以看到
时至今日
那个融资在上次这样洗刷过后
在最近又在洗刷的时候
我们的融资率还是勇敢地
占上了6000亿以上
就是这个增加的幅度
根本就没有在洗
然后围台也是
围台其实连续两个月
都是一个非常勇敢做多
我们也说
微台以前我們以為是大盤的反指標
現在看起來也叫勇敢微台
聰明微台
可是這些事情累積到後面
它會不會再產生一個再平衡
我覺得會
所以這一波融資
你都打死不退
今天可能就真的會痛
今天真的會痛
所以我覺得
既然5月底那一波
燒到42,000沒有洗
這一波現在到44,000
凱哥說可能支撐在43,600的部分
這一波如果能夠再洗乾淨一下
是有利於接下來的行情
因為我們進入到台藝店法說前的得點圈了
可是現在卻沒有辦法表現
因為最近在我們福爾的問題
在美國、日本、韓國、台灣
日本可能好一點
連日本是想生息
生息也算是一種溫和收縮
那都已經在呈現這樣的現象的時候
我們就留意
我們常常講基本面
上面有一層泡泡
泡泡多是好喝
可是泡泡消風的時候
我們自己要保護自己
那今天趙華幹嘛呢
還是一樣
我有跟凱哥報告
我說一樣嘛
破月線對不對
大黑K
那甚至早了点
我跌到一千多点的时候
就进去捡了一些ETF
就从跌一千点
变成跌一千八百点
再捡一些ETF
个股就有一点小观望
不过确实我发现
载版跟实盈元件
应该是今天盘面上最亮眼的
只是涨点有些后来都收敛掉
好 所以我按照我的纪律就是
我觉得不是因为
景气出问题的反转
我就破月线的大黑K
然后一千点以上
我就加码一些
那有没有可能去记线
其实贵买上一次是有要去测季线的
大盘还没有
如果再去测季线
只要是经济环境的前提不变的情况下
我还是会在季线附近继续加
这就是我现在的一个策略
因为你会发现有个好处
你不要再V上去
就是已经停了上去了
然后才急急忙忙的追
压力就会非常大
例如我也承认
我上礼拜或说这礼拜一
我也会觉得很FOMO
买一点个股好了
涨的时候好高薪的个股都涨停
今天怎么样
吐回去嘛
个股就是这样
所以我们自己在进出场的逻辑跟想法上
一定要先确立起来
说实话今天要不要心情差不需要
因为今天又是一个可能你做中场线波段
ETF相对好的买点
对因为这盘基本上确实贵买就比较弱
对你仔细看其实贵买
它是破了近期的连续三根大量的低了
而且它月线是下弯的
所以势必告诉你贵买会进行一段的整理
那你很多个股涨多了
它就跟着整理了
你像被动人间这些
关5分钟
关20分钟的一大堆
今天就纷纷就打回来了
就是因为这个气氛太冷了
对
你经不住这样的气氛
你不敢再去追了
就下来了
但是我刚刚讲说
像新元件他们还在往上走
就告诉你
基本上这个缺货的概念没有结束
老实讲
你就算被动人件这样打下来
它缺货这个影响数改变了吗
没有
它还是存在的
只是你的股价是要做一个修正之后
回来重新再出发
所以我觉得原先讲的那一些族群
还是可以留意
我记得你看嘛
我们昨天在讲说
利隆店要调涨报价
然后这个铝电容的交期拉长
然后之前是我还有提过
像大义也纳入了这个NVIDIA的供应链
其实这些都还是
回过头还是可以看
就是说你去看它涨完之后
我如果没记得到大义千年
还在拉涨停
所以告诉你其实
不要因为今天的大跌
就让你失去信心了
我们刚才讲说
今天的大跌
其实某种程度是好处
就是把一些福尔洗掉
然后稍微把杠杆做一点收敛
因为今天其实
你看到前几天
都已经就要看到五万了
对啊
这有点太夸张
我必须这样讲
就是今天行情走得有点
让大家觉得有点可怕
可怕是说钱赚进来太可怕
所以你看很多人就是
只要一个月月薪有
他就想要离职
那这样很多企业组
就会受到影响了
因为很多企业体
很多人都运工要离开
那所以这不是一件好事情
还是让专职的专业经营人
来做投资
你把钱去买ETF
让他们来帮你做判断
去做投资
你自己就是
我觉得就是斜杠
而不是把它当做主业
现在很多人是
把股票当主业
所以股票一涨一跌
你现在就上不了班了
你的心情就很差
所以你搞不好笑
你就说
老板今天不想
不想继续上班
会先回家休息
其实这个都
在在都影响到不正常
其实都不正常
其实你要像午后照话一样
心如止水
就今天大跌大涨
其实我们都不会有太大的担忧
就是我们只要看得懂
趋势在哪里
就没有害怕
目前趋势还在
所以不用太害怕
比较担心的就是
像今天Apple讲说
它要调涨它的产品售价了
因为它的产品
基本上很多的componer拿不到
还记不记得我们之前在讲说
南电被这个Apple包产了
其实那时候Apple就看到
整个一个AI大幅的侵蚀
它的原件的供应
所以它现在开始要调整报价
可是你要知道
其实Apple在AI这一挂
其实是不领先的
是很落后的
所以它没有跟上AI这一步
但是它的产品基本上缺乏AI情况下
基本上卖不太动
你又要调整报价
所以大家担心其实是
整个市场的消费力
是不是在衰退中
因为AI很强
大家都把钱花到AI上
但我觉得还好啦
因为其实我就问嘛
有多少人真的是
像我们一样是重度的AI使用者
其实还是不多的啦
所以我觉得现在还是在长一个预期心理
所以我觉得还是不用太害怕
好因为你讲到Apple手机
我刚才也是想说要跟你来讨论
好像照不出来
因为上次有人特地为了想要看
我的Apple手机摔成什么一个鬼德性
我现在再试试看
可能看不到
我昨天就觉得好后悔
因为我i17没有换嘛我想說沒關係啦iPhone18啦而且我內心還有點小思心想说有啊苹果那时候去跟三星谈啊要包他记忆体的产能可能不会长太多就算长一咪咪吧
然后呢
我就裸机在那边用
我的iPhone15
哇摔的是一个乱七八糟
昨天就跟他说
对不起
我不应该摔你的
因为iPhone18要涨价了
他们说
3000到8000不等
然后有一些平板
可能1万
对
哇
幸好我没有那么的迷恋平板
可是我本来要换iPhone18
会啦我还是会换
可是那种感觉就是
早知道我就不要这样
对它那么坏了
还可以继续用
或者是对它更坏
我就先换iPhone17
好没有没有对不起
不要这样说
等一下忽然给我故障掉
好苹果这件事情
昨天在美股是一个很大的压力
因为苹果自己跌6%多之外
就如凯哥说的
都是在发展AI
当然如果你有做到AI
可能你的公司的成效
或是股价就很好
可是如果今天
让消费品开始变贵
会不会大家就比较
不想要买手机
也不想要換機了呢
因為蘋果如果iPhone18賣不好
可能整體對手機市場的期待
又會下降囉
那還有誰今天是受害呢
例如說像聯發科
雖然今年漲上來
都是因為講ethica的部分
可是畢竟它還是大塊在手機市場
如果今年的手機市場
或是到明年的狀況是不好的
你看發哥今天就給你一個跌停表態
所以整體的消費
會不會因為各個消費品
受到短缺記憶體
短缺零件而上漲
然後導致消費市場低迷
然后整体的经济可能会被拉下来
我觉得这也是在昨天跟今天
大跌的一个原因之一
对 因为大家觉得消费力道
有点在甩腿
对
因为想嘛 其实手机一直长一长
然后你又觉得
你好像换下去好像没什么意义
因为整个手机长基本上就饱和啦
其实很多人都还在用iPhone 15
iPhone 16
我
是不是 很多人都在用
甚至还有人用到iPhone 13的
所以大家其实感
没有迫切的需要换手机
那你没有换手机
基本上之前带动全球电子市场
往上成长的就是iPhone
那你现在iPhone
告诉你它已经要停滞了
但市场会有点担心
会很担心
因为毕竟整个一个AI
目前是它没有实质获利跳出来的
它还是在一个
持续的在投资的阶段里面
还没有到开始要一直收钱进来
可是你原本觉得说
我口袋有不断的现金流露的
这些厂商开始他没有
明显的获利进来的时候
他会不会没办法支撑
要来持续投入
所以微软好像昨天也跌嘛
是 对就告诉你说
其实大家担心的是这个
但是我觉得还要担心的啦
就是我不知道大家有没有注意到
其实最近的美股里面
其实一些重量的科技股
有点使不上力
虽然我们看到二哥AMD一直在往上走
月星也在往上走
也在新高的附近
可是我们的老大
我们的教主上次来台湾之后
他的股价其实没有上来
NVIDIA股价是越先下弯的
而且它形实形态是比较偏弱的
我们只能解读说
因为看起来它在这个世代
我们在Computest看的这个世代的产品
不是主流产品
它是一个过渡型的产品
所以会不会在Ultra的时候
它才会领先上工
这个是要持续做观察
但是我基本上我认为
就是它的这个Rubin
应该还是一个过渡型的产品
再来解释说为什么
很多人会觉得说NVIDIA很弱
所以AI的公司
台湾应该要落
我不这么认为冤在说
因为你看老二AMD
他的股价其实是在
新高的边缘上面
而且他还在往上走
所以告诉你持期比落
就是有人是落下来的
可是他还在往上走啊
对 所以不要因为
龙头教主的股价比较弱
你就觉得好像全盘揭没
不是这样的看法啦
好 那因为今天外资空单回补
我们这几天也有跟大家分享
因为前两天外资空单到了
八万三千口
但是那时候正价差真的很大
正价差
如果用夜盤來看有時候一度會拉到一千點的增價差
那今天這個增價差不見了
不見了 那我們的外資空單就會有參考的意義
今天外資空單是有這樣下來的
所以下個禮拜我覺得這個事情
我們就恢復到參考這件事情上
因為如果沒有套利的需求
那剩下就是避險以及
因為你說是避險沒有錯
可是它如果現貨也在賣
那就代表說它有一點純空方的味道
這件事情我覺得下禮拜要來
就是好好的觀測一下
没有这个套利的需求的话
那当然在现货市场
因为现在台币的汇率是真的比较差
因为美元在升嘛
美元在升就是呼应他们觉得9月
卢凯歌他有提到
他不是叫升息
他叫预防性升息
可是好处是什么
好处就跟华许那天的会议一样
假设真的预防性升息了
反而有可能叫利空出境
因为现在在反映利空
现在在反映这个担忧
所以如果担忧成真
或是担忧拿掉的时候
又會是好事
所以市場永遠充滿了
這些要綜合評估的事情
但我覺得如果你把它事情
叫做大到治檢回來的話
第一觀測盤面上
到底誰還是強勢族群
國際市場誰是強勢族群
因為剛剛凱哥講到被動元件
昨天太陽又電
村田製造所不是還在大漲特長嗎
不用因為一天
就覺得事情好像完了
沒有了
功率元件其實也是同樣的道理
那當然美股現在AI的大型龍頭股
都有一点點像凱哥講的
使不上力
可是还有一些二军都还在高点附近
今天矽光子有一家叫和胜挂牌了
就是光胜的子公司
从200多一路800多
然后后来收我刚刚看收在640块
当然光胜自己就有点辛苦了
看来资金要买会想要去买和胜
但和胜也因为今天的盘比较闷
要不然搞不好800多就上去了
但是不要第一天抢这个事情
我们有很多的不好的经验
哈哈哈
没有
你要钱还是可以
不要买太多
就好像我就跟我台讲说
对
你合胜300块以下
都是可以闭着眼睛嘛
对不对
但是800
但是500块以上你就要很小心
你要有点心理的准备
对
因为很多很多
应该讲说有一批资金是专门在做这样
刚新贵过的股票
所以他们的一开盘
他们是挂很高的价格
他们可能都是开800 900直接买进的
对
所以你如果是他开100多
你想要挂个两三百
基本上成交要碰运气喔
真的不太容易买到
但是如果你买到真的就是运气好
好 这个是大家可以留意的啦
因为毕竟当初我们很关注和尚的挂牌
对 但是他今天挂牌是遇到一个
戚风苦雨
我们的天气也是戚风苦雨
所以我觉得大力光是不是今天因为这样
所以要掉下来
为什么
他搞不好一方面是因为这个Apple
可是一方面可能也是因為
我覺得Apple也有光了
因為他們兩個都做的都是
細光子的臨近的這一塊
對 但是算這個路徑是不一樣的
但是方向是一樣的
是 但戴力光今天是破十日線
還是強於大盤
國劇今天也是打到快十日線
也是強於大盤
也等於是不用那麼快下定論
但是我們自己要理解
往下像趙華的想法就是
只要像這種破月線的時候
我都是去買
例如說市值型的ETF為主
會比較放心
或是你買一些
像我今天看了
最近主動式的ETV
績效度跑的不一樣
例如說前一陣的991A跑得特別好
所以今天他根本就只是在腳那邊接近月線
可是像981A最近比較辛苦
981A今天就一個長黑破月線
那你要去撿這個比較弱的
還是等比較強的下來
我覺得都可以
因為他們這種還在賽跑
都才掛牌一年的東西
都還在賽跑
所以我還是按照我的機率
有破的我先撿一些
沒破的我也掛在月線那邊等等看
我就是用這樣的一個想法
然後讓他們去跑
那當然我會密切注意的是
這一些像蘋果的事情為什麼特別留意
我也會擔心會不會大家在消費品上面
越來越不肯消費
然後可是不肯消費
他們又因為零組件的漲價
不得不越來越變得更貴
形成的惡性循環
我覺得這個是比較不好的
但是AI的發展這件事情
倒看起來市場還是非常的買單
所以到底股市會在裡面什麼時候找到平衡我們可能需要一點觀察以及我也很支持凱哥講的融資真的洗一下每次都會覺得我凹單就會大賺我槓桿開了我也不會有去槓桿的痛
上一次跌到4萬2也沒人斷頭
那這樣子其實你總有累積一定是要還的
是
剛剛講到基金
我們還是那個邏輯
就是說一樣
基金也是可以跟個股的邏輯是一樣的
你去觀察它的月線的走勢
当一档基金的月线走势开始往下弯的时候
你就开始不要再加码了
因为稍微有点不太对
真的 可是我喜欢那种
减便宜的
破月线跟月线下弯是两码之势
破月线是可以加码的
可是当它月线下弯的时候
你就先不要加码
也许它可能是短线的影响
但是它如果过几天又拉起来
那就没事
我懂你意思
可是如果它连续一个礼拜
月线都持续下弯
那就告诉你说
它的持股可能有些偏差了
這是給大家做參考
好 我在幫凱哥翻譯舉例
大家會想說沒有啊 正好不是說去基線還要買
這是兩種不同的思維
一種是 如果你的基金是那種很積極的
就例如說它是某一種特殊產業的
它是比較積極的 你自己就要考量一下
因為它波動可能大
所以當它越先下彎 它可能伴隨來的會是
你已經可以預測到 也許是一大段的跌幅
那你手上的錢怎麼配呢
假如你是一個定期定額
或是你本來就是越跌越減
你有留錢的人 我覺得沒有關係
對 因為像台灣的科技股或是半導體
或者是說整體市值
你說要跌到沒有嗎
這不太可能啦
所以如果你是已經做好資金配置跟進場策略的人
你可以這樣做
但是如果你的錢就那麼一點點
你可能加個一兩次你就會沒有的人
你可能就很留意這件事情喔
因為你可能加完一個月線後面點
你就都加不到 你就會很痛苦
你甚至覺得我要停損嗎
怎麼辦我錢被卡住了
所以我覺得這種思維和我們
你會覺得很奇怪
為什麼照華說越低越減
凱哥說越下萬不要減
其實是取決於你的進場配置的策略
你的商品 你的資金還剩下多少
是
好 那這邊的話還是要問一下凱哥
我剛剛有講的下禮拜我會觀察一下
例如說融資跟外資的一些變化
那你會主要觀察在什麼
因為國際市場
你說有沒有什麼大型的財寶什麼
下禮拜都還好
我覺得基本上很快的就要台鑫法說
那大家都知道台鑫這次的法說有兩個重點
一個是資本支出 一個是毛利率
那毛利率基本上它一定是往上走的
它上个月应该是
上一季应该是接近65、66了
那我觉得它接下来就会往70去
所以它其实是越来越好
越来越好其实代表它的什么
它的获利越来越高
它也不断持续在扩大它的资本支出
资本投入
那资本支出看起来
它就算这次没有讲
下次也有讲
应该是扩大资本支出
所以它的设备
它的应允
它的建厂
这些一定都是跟着往上走的
所以下礼拜
除我们刚刚讲的
实行原件这些以外
像前几天有拉到涨停的汉堂
或是像亚翔
这种其实下来
其实他们都没有涨很多
其实他们是很稳健
慢慢就往上爬
我觉得相对来讲
今天这样一个风暴
我觉得对他们的影响不会太大
他们就继续往上走
不会因为这样就结束
一样这个设备也是
就是你去观察就是下一个阶段
台积电的
Cowars到Corpus這邊的設備機台的廠商
他們應該也是會持續順風順水的往上走
那這個就是我們在下一階段可以提醒大家
可以特別去留意的個股跟族群
好 就是比較肯定的就是
其實我們好像共識都很一致
就是台積電相關的設備供應鏈
昨天雲翔哥來也是這麼講
就是因為全世界的建廠都要到他們的手上
而且這個在業界真的也跟大家分享過很多次
就是有這個很大的封測廠就講說嘛
說以前就是覺得叫你來建廠是大家來招標啊
對不對
啊到底這樣一支標金最好的人拿到嘛
就所謂最合理的人拿到
他現在就是一直留標
因為大家都說你那麼便宜
我去蓋別人的就好了
所以他們每一個人都只好去提高這個標的價格
廠商才會願意承接
所以這些廠物工程設備類的
真的是訂單是非常非常之滿
那他也考验到像今天有好多公司
也是一口气就打到跌停板的时候
你要优先选择谁
或者是你也不急的今天一定要选择啊
你也可以等到这个风暴稍微
比较指稳一点点的时候再来做
可是切记不要在这种大涨三天
要创新高的时候
才突然觉得自己又没有进去追
其实我觉得这一波
如果节奏上没有搞错的人
今天也不一定很有感觉
对也不一定很有感觉
反而会开始思考
又来到有很多公司
可能也接近到月線的位置了
他們的月線還在上揚
他們的業績也沒有問題
我可能接下來資金要打到哪一些族群上面
那設備是我跟凱哥的共識比較高的
那至於你說功率元件
被動元件
雖然它的勢頭看起來很好
可是要不要追高
我覺得這個也是考驗著大家自己的資金
對啊 不是沒有長
是已經長一段了
對 所以手上有的朋友
像我自己手上還是有蠻多的被動元件
和小部分的功率元件
我也沒有在做什麼奇怪的動作
因為他們離成本區很遠
更遑論像載板這樣的公司
但是我也沒有打算在今天
就急著進去
然後趕快撿
我覺得這個想法
我覺得大家可以互相參考一下
因為每一個人的操作邏輯不一樣
那當然我們也有聽到
有些大戶朋友
這幾天其實是有點
腳底抹油
賺了就走
所以想要請教凱哥
你身邊的比較多的大戶朋友
會認為這一波修正
或者是說
他可能已經提早提款一些東西了
什麼時候歸對會比較好
我觉得很多大户在这个时间离场
其实他是看不出什么不对劲
只是觉得就是说
赚到了
好像这盘在这边晃晃晃
好像拿一点钱出来好了
再来就是因为暑假也快要到了
所以大家都是带小孩出去玩什么的
所以这时间接下来可能就会有一些大户旅游潮
就是他们出去旅游了
他们可能会暂时把资金先抽出来
可是会不会还会再回来
我说应该是还有机会
为什么
因为他们不是全部出厂的
他们是部分出厂
而且我刚刚讲
部分出厂其实
你看也没有跌很重嘛
他们主要卖的族群
所以我在跟大家讲说
基本上我看到
像CPU这个族群的主力是没有走的
所以我还是认为第三季
CPU应该会有机会啦
好 大户出去玩
然后现在还有世足赛
其实我们之前
可能比较少讲这个啦
以玄学的角度
其实也是科学
世足赛的期间
股票市场不容易涨
他说因为有一部分的钱
會挪到賭資嘛
賭資
然後有一部分的錢
可能就是大家會覺得
我要去旅遊
我要去看
我要守在電視前面之類的
然後所以
可能不是守在電視前面
守在網路前面
我突然講我們電視台
也是有辛苦的地方
所以它在關注度
還有資金流的部分
也會被分散
那說是巧合嗎
我也不確定
因為現在就是世足賽的期間
而且這個六月
又讓你歡喜
又讓你憂
就是又創了新高
但是又打回一个原点
这种感觉
希望大家如果操作节奏抓得好
其实问题倒是不大
我昨天是说
每次都是夜盘在杀
日盘又好了
白天不懂夜的黑
那今天要改一首歌
叫做开始懂了
开始比较吻合了
可是你知道吗
比较吻合是好的
你就比较不会进退
觉得很痛苦
说现在跟夜盘的差距这么大
棋子跟台股的差距那么大
等到大家都贴合
融资也稍微洗出去
然后大户在归队的时候
我觉得市场秩序
就会慢慢再恢复了
对 因为还是那句话啦
台积电的这个法说
一定是很正面的
不用太担心
所以我觉得这个盘
基本上
既然政府不开融资给大家用
就代表政府希望
这个行情可以走更远
也可以走得更稳
我想这个是给大家
比较良心的建议
就这个盘还不用太害怕
好 那我们今天是礼拜五
希望大家六日
也要小心下雨
下到已经有点灾情了
出路小心但是好好地休息
那就跟古惑仔的朋友说拜拜咯
大家拜拜
下周再见
拜拜